[Musique]
dites nous quelles sont vos informations
comment ça évolue maintenant écouter
samantha l'attention elle est toujours
aussi palpable on a affaire désormais un
face à face assez marquées entre
certains manifestants habillés de noir
cagoulés et les forces de l'ordre donc
des forces de l'ordre qui répondent par
gaz lacrymogènes un par des tirs de gaz
lacrymogènes en réponse aux nombreux
tirs de projectiles et qu'il reçoit des
forces de l'ordre qu'ils ont qui ont
reculé de quelques mètres
on sent que là la tension est de plus en
plus palpable les la manifestation est
pour le moment bloqué les
les manifestants se trouvent
actuellement sur la place des invalides
s'il est impossible pour eux d'avancer à
davantage en tout cas pas cas pas avant
que la situation ne ne se calment donc
on a aussi de nombreux pompiers qui est
bien viennent d'intervenir pour à
éteindre les nombreux feux de poubelles
qui ont été qui ont été allumés a ici à
quelques à quelques mètres donc voilà
une tension qui est de plus en plus
palpable on voit qu'il ya beaucoup
d'agitation aussi à derrière nous
puisque donc on voit là il est
impossible très difficile de respirer
ici quoi qu'il en soit on va rejoindre à
un brancardier 1 2 de l'hôpital d'ivry
s'appelle rémy rémy déjà avant de nous
dire pourquoi est-ce que vous avez tenu
à être présent aujourd'hui
que vous inspire le sait cette
dégradation de 2 de cette manifestation
qui avait très bien commencé en début
d'après midi
je regrette sincèrement cette situation
et d'autres beaucoup de progrès depuis
ce que je fais partie du collectif inter
hospitalier que vous représentez et ça
me fait mal au coeur de voir ça en robes
pour qu'on redoute et malheureusement on
a l'expérience des anciennes
manifestations qu'on peut voir pour
médias
ça m'attriste profondément parce que
depuis le début tout se passer
correctement
c'était une manifestation bon enfant on
sait faire entendre et en arriver à
attaquer les forces de l'ordre ne s'est
pas sûr que non ça nous serve à quelque
chose
nous les forces de l'ordre on les voit
quand on passe à côté en laurent les
salue on a du respect pour eux voilà est
allé leur foncer dedans ou leur balancer
des trucs directement c'est inacceptable
inacceptable et en aucun cas nous on
veut que la manifestation des soignants
qui se veut symbolique vient de causer
des dégâts ni aux forces de l'ordre ni
la république ni aux biens publics parce
que je suis en train de voir ça crame de
pathos
explique-moi rémy pourquoi est ce qu'il
dit vous avez tenu à être présent
aujourd'hui vous vous dites que c'est de
plus en plus difficile qu'au bout de
ferraille d'exercer votre de métier
pourquoi parce que on n'a pas assez de
personnel mais voilà les patients et ils
sont plus au coeur ils sont plus au
coeur de la préoccupation directement et
nous on veut plus que le patient
devienne une calculette voilà le fric on
s'en fout voilà c'est à eux de gérer
directement illenoo ce qu'on veut c'est
des moyens humains pour pouvoir
s'occuper des patients correctement une
augmentation une augmentation de salaire
pardon pour pouvoir nous vivre de notre
métier correctement et des moyens
supplémentaires dans chaque service
voilà parce qu'un service de réa
beaucoup plus de moyens a besoin de plus
de moyens qu'un service de médecine et
et le service de métier a beaucoup plus
de moyens qu à notre service voilà
aujourd'hui nous serons réclament c'est
une augmentation de salaires une
augmentation de moyens humains et une
augmentation de matériel est ce que est
ce que l'état français allait a les
moyens justement de répondre à ses
revendications et d'augmenter tout le
monde
la santé n'a pas de prix pour reprendre
une phrase du président de la république
on attend de voir du coup
parce que visiblement ça a dû sa pensée
pour l'économie quand et pour l'aviation
et c'est là on peut débloquer les fonds
et on n'est pas de donner à ses girls a
pas besoin d'attendre cette semaine pour
ce qui nous concerne mais à chaque fois
on a que du blabla on veut juste du
complète mon sens on marche depuis
thaler symboliquement parce qu'on sait
très bien qu'on va être écouté
aujourd'hui c'est la première c'est
symbolique
voilà et une nouvelle fois je me permets
de le redire je suis désolé mais je jeu
mais presque au nom du collectif et je
m'excuse de céder barreteau deux de ces
débordements
je ne peux pas les tolérer je ne peux
pas les accepter et les vivres parce que
je me suis fait gazer pour mais j'en
veux pas non plus aux forces de l'ordre
ils font leur travail et essaie de
maintenir quelque chose voilà nous on
les veut avec nous on n'est pas mieux là
pour casser du flic complètement merci
rémi merci de votre témoignage
vous l'avez entendu un sagna les
personnels hospitaliers qui réclament
plus de moyens rémy qui est bien on
appelle au président de la république
pourrait bien soutenir l'hôpital public
parce que la santé n'a pas de prix a dit
il il reprend les propos du président de
la république
emmanuel macron qui a appelé merci
beaucoup à ne pas manifester
avant-hier lundi dimanche à ne pas
manifester parce qu'il estime que ces
manifestations sont bien des foyers
potentiels de contamination à quoi qu'il
en soit la tension est toujours palpable
sur cette place des invalides on voit au
loin de nouvelles poubelles incendiées
et des forces de l'ordre qui est bien
désormais encadrent l'intégralité de
cette place des invalides donc très
compliqué d'en sortir
voilà une manifestation qui qui dégénère
et qui ne sert pas la cause des
soignants et bien pour reprendre les
propos de rémy brancardier donc à
l'hôpital d'evry